non ci posso credere
[Musica]
mentre ai leader di oggi a
grandissima richiesta
nuovi live che
facebook che non avrò visti in
particolare su quello che vuoi vedere
che mi avete mandato in tanti su
instagram è super corredo di vederlo ho
fatto tantissimi videos line face se non
li avete visti poi vi lascio il link
alla playlist ma continuate a chiedermi
ogni giorno di fare anche perché mentre
se perché vieni pertite troppo che mi fa
troppo ridere che volete vedere la mia
reazione insomma che volete vedere
niente mohammed e quindi sono andata a
cercare dei nuovi clienti e che ha
trovato come un po che non ho ancora
visto perché ovviamente abbiamo vederli
insieme se volete vederne il nostro più
belle like a 10 mia vice farò un altro
video come questo con nuovi tra imprese
e ora siete per un disco corno fatine il
video tutto schermo iniziamo subito che
vende un prodotto aspetta o che il primo
figlio sta aggiungendo un
lucida labbra un rossetto mount lime
abbiamo come diventa
ma non si è sciolto tipo rimasto un
intero ma non lo sei note di tutto
finora da non era così male questo
quando qualcuno sta moltissimo nel
permetto di un smr
effettivamente trasporti con le cuffie
poiché fa lei quando pensi che ci sia
tantissimo tutti la
prima che una bugia
quando c'è il rumore di sottofondo che
sembra come se ci fosse ci sia un
aspirapolvere
quando expert line non si rompe in
pezzettini ma da 8 giu questo l'ho visto
tante volte per l'iphone prime
prossimo il abbiano un bellissimo
[Musica]
iniziamo con la violenza subita time tv
rimasto tutto abc color terra avviata
vediamo se lo picchia
e così
picchiano
[Musica]
ciò che è prossimo capisce niente cosa
che sta tirando fuori il blind da un
contenitore a quanto pare rimasto un po
attaccato da queste vittore
questi squadrature ravvicinate
dell'editto solamente
che bello
trasparente
cosa
[Musica]
mi manda dentro
forse per fare la fame le far credere
che fosse vero in puzzle non capisco
chi abbassa un po il volume che qualcuno
tocca
a mettendo così
che
sembrava carino
no e nessuna per
non far vedere il taxi suoi
[Musica]
un miglio
[Applauso]
[Musica]
picchiare la smetta con offerta
ok sempre questo delle
che
[Musica]
la immerso completamente
in pressing slime vediamo
nero è rimasto e per calcio
questo è forse è vero
ho capito perchè
[Musica]
sinceramente tipo dice latina in
pressing prime
[Musica]
vabbè questo nella sabbia era nascosta
al suono del iv trim
fantastico ma non pensavo letto molto il
commento in cui mi avete detto bailly
slime al mare con la sabbia ovviamente
non mettendolo in mezzo alla fabia ma
prende il gruppo di sabbia per non
inquinare se vi interessa che lo faccia
o scrivetelo nei commenti
fans nei post
non so perché fanno così di moda questi
risparmi in cui metti dentro un iphone
ipod o qualsiasi prodotto apple
c'è un'alta
statico mischiano un'alga a walter
plaikner obiettivo
[Musica]
penso che fa che profumo questo è il
risultato
oddio ancora detto aggiungendo penso che
sia un alga scrivete nei commenti
secondo me coaster bellissimo e lo stai
più bello che abbia mai visto
oddio
ho scritto che in realtà è molto creato
in sé 4 note della schiuma da barba
[Musica]
eccolo
faccio il colorante non mi dire che
vuole mischiare così senza colla
secchino e poi che vuoi fare
ora come fare il pressing sulla scritta
forma ma un calzino
alcune idee come vengono in mente va
bene sperimentare memorizzino fatto con
la stellina penso
che sta mischiando il tutto
non si sa ancora molto bene purtroppo ho
questa dei clipper bellissimi
[Musica]
un computer a uno starnuto murlo
pressing e mettiamo
[Musica]
ma forse tutto fermo
oddio
ed ecco che quindi scalarla picchia lo
posso propri ragazzi questo me lo avete
mandato in tantissimi su instagram
ma era solo un mini video dello trovati
nel gabinetto appunto e non c'era
insomma il continuo ho trovato il video
in cui questi fanno lo prendo il
gabinetto e poi non ha ora messo non so
cosa succede ma l'ho capito dal titolo
comunque non vi dico niente guardiamo
insieme e vediamo cosa succede ho paura
veramente comunque
stanno facendo lo slime
live normale quindi non quello con la
polverina che si può stare nella vasca
ad esempio
la folla sono il destino diamoci anche
questo fanno di colore verde
colorante
[Musica]
per questo ha mischiato
che strano come ma le chat offline
[Musica]
quello
ma era pronto
[Musica]
a
non ci posso credere è più ammesso da
fare al caminetto e ci sono anche altri
che l'hanno fatto questo è il primo
video più o meno completo
[Musica]
ma non è finita qua ragazze non è finita
qua perché
nel titolo c'è scritto
che
tirava scarico appunto
per vedere se scelto il giu
confermo adesso per riempire tutto il
gabinetto
ha fatto così tanto
nuova moda giocare con lo slam fare
working nel caminetto
seriamente pensavo di averle viste tutte
ma questa le ha superate tutte veramente
social scioccate
ok ok allora
[Musica]
lo stava alzando tutto per quel che la
luce a cuore
che
stesso
treni mentre
[Musica]
non ce la posso fare
finora lo schifo che abbiamo vinto
[Musica]
ma l'acqua che sta diventando brutta
dall'altra
attivo in questo intento
è una struttura guardare questo video
[Musica]
dovevo chiamare questo video prova
[Applauso]
anzitutto è sceso giu non ci posso
credere
speravo che si interruppe il gabinetto
così impara a votare l'uno flyng perché
ovviamente non lo fate mai non buttare
mai cose del genere nel gabinetto perché
primo potrebbe intarsi e che fare un
carpi non risparmiare tutto su e fare
casino secondo inquina inquina
tantissimo quindi non lo fate mai e sono
scioccata questi sono scioccata dai temi
si sa bene quale egli ha giocato di più
ma penso che anche voi abbiamo giocato
di più questo del gabinetto comunque ce
ne sono altri di questi tipi di video in
cui mettono a mostrarmi un caminetto e
tirano l'acqua io sono assolutamente
contro perché ve l'ho detto e
inquinamento e potrebbe incassare tutto
fare casino però se volete che ne
vediamo altre assieme se volete che
soffra ancora
più bello anche se questo video le muse
in diecimila da ex farò altri implied
facebook fatemi sapere come piccoli
altri tipi di video vorreste vedere e mi
lasciò rappa 4 caselline in cui potete
cliccare per vedere i prossimi video sul
sito della stessa impresa sociale
duplicate se quello che preferite e
buona visione